mi nombre es paola pérez soy de
venezuela atleta olímpica en la
disciplina de aguas abiertas me fui a
venezuela porque ya las piscinas no
estaban funcionando y quería seguir
participando en los siguientes juegos
olimpia
mucha gente se va al país por cuestiones
de económicas
yo en realidad me fui por una cuestión
de piscina que ya no habían piscinas y
ese es mi
me medio por el cual me muevo y eso fue
lo que en realidad me obligó a salir
buscar una piscina donde puedes entrenar
dos veces al día
yo trabajo de clases de natación y
trabajo afecta un poco en mi rendimiento
de entrenamiento a veces el dinero no me
alcanza como tal
gabrielle gifford min porque no me han
dado el financiamiento que que requiero
para esta preparación
y ya se estaba agotando el tiempo y dije
tengo que buscar la manera decidí todas
las sesiones entrenamiento que tengo
ahora hacerlas a morir de principio a
fin e ir investigando cómo aprovechar
ese tiempo que no tengo en el agua
aprovechando en la tierra y eso también
hace que tenga que estudiar investigar y
apasionarme un poco más de esto pero
desde el punto de vista de atleti
también como de entrenador porque uno
también tiene que hacer como de todo en
este momento
para mí ganar la medalla en los
panamericanos fue una sorpresa pero no
me lo esperaba inclusive cuando toque la
meta dije bueno como es esto que para mí
quedarse está en un panamericano era
guau
y cuando salga mi entrenador como
sollozando y yo por lo que pasó no quedó
de tercera y no me lo podía creer mi
próximo objetivo es el preolímpico que
hay sabré si tengo o no el pase a los
juegos olímpicos de tokio
estoy como un poco a ciegas pero me
siento física y mentalmente bien
cambiado para mejor me siento más fuerte
más madura porque para hacer esto
también hay que tener
madurez deportiva pero al final es mi
sueño si yo soy la única que no puede
hacer posible